once you grasp how to be good at AI it's
the critical thinking and the creative
thinking input that people are going to
put into these platforms into these
search bars and I think it's going to
create really Dynamic work and so I
think at first people are going to meet
it with fear they did that with the
internet they did that with social media
they did that with the iPhone but I
think over the next three or five years
we'll have a more healthy view on it
that I find will be balanced meaning
there'll be some pros and there'll be
some cons like everything a lot of
people have been talking about capacity
efficiency you know it's been a really
interesting theme for the last several
years of me trying to dissect what I see
Works in our organization and other
organizations
um are there any common themes and I
genuinely do believe that one of the
things that hurts a lot of people is
meetings run long and meetings have too
many people in them I think you know I
think all of us are striving for good
work cultures for our employees and
there's a lot of things one can do but I
really do think helping educate like
the value of a two-hour meeting with 21
people if that meeting happened to be
you know 45 minutes with seven people
miraculously a lot of hours are freed up
for people to be able to achieve what
they need to in a day and so just
spending a lot of time trying to figure
out how to eliminate anxiousness lack of
productivity and I do think meetings is
one of the big culprits out there I mean
literally the meeting I had right before
this was 15 minutes but only took seven
you know like I think I do think a good
15-minute meeting especially when you
have capable Executives you can get
right into it I mean I'm I'm thrilled
for banter and jokes and I love all that
stuff too quite a bit I probably am a
culprit of making meetings go too long
with a little bit of like the side dish
or bringing some of the emotion to it
but you know I I really like to get to
the heart of the matter
um I think that's important and I think
a lot of times even in the context of
our industry Sometimes the best ideas
for a campaign or a marketing uh
execution sometimes have in the first 30
minutes I find a lot of fresh ideas or
the first take or the intuition of the
most capable creative people I think
they sometimes talk themselves out of
stuff the longer they stay and stuff and
so yeah I mean it runs the gamut you
know I think one of the biggest
elephants in the room in our industry is
reach in frequency is something I
believe in heavily as well it's just
that I think our industry speaks about
reaching frequency as if it's actually
being consumed as if the reach is
actually being consumed my brain
vayner's point of view is that there's
potential reach and there's actualized
reach and I believe that the Super Bowl
is disproportionately the strongest
actualized reach advertising that we
have in America and so look it's a huge
ticket you know I don't I don't laugh at
seven million dollars or sneeze at it
but when you can get a hundred million
Americans to actually pay attention
and actually consume it you know it's
very different than the Oscars that's
very different than the NBA Finals
that's very different than anything you
can do on digital it's just I feel like
when you really get to the matter and
we're not robots yet AI has not been
implanted in us and all this other stuff
so we don't know the actualized
consumption of all the reach that we do
in all platforms but I think everyone in
our industry can absolutely agree that
Super Bowl's actually being consumed the
problem is you have to make the creative
land right the creative is still the
variable so you can blow it but the
media planning the cons of it the
planning of the media I think is the
strongest in the industry yeah I mean
first of all I'm always in a tricky spot
because I'm not watching at home I'm
usually at the game because I'm an avid
football fan so I didn't consume the
commercials this year but
I thought the 2B commercial really
caught my attention because I'm big on
breaking patterns I think it's you know
this world is noisy you know this you
you and your contemporaries do such a
great job covering this industry and
you're taking in on a daily basis a
drillion campaigns just on a daily basis
think about what how that plays out over
the course of the year so to break
through to these 300 million Americans
or even more importantly 8 billion
people Global it's hard so I thought
what they did was very clever because
they played the utility of the whole
thing they shocked everyone they made
them stop and they made them pay
attention and that you know I think
that's that was really really well done
and so that one kind of took the cake
for me because it wasn't about like oh
cool there's this cool actor in it or oh
cool that was funny or silly or
emotional it was functional and I
thought that was very clever the point I
was making in that talk and and really
My overall
passion of being in this industry is
layering Common Sense against pricing
against actual consumer behavior and so
my point with print is and listen I was
a heavy print Advertiser in the late 90s
early 2000s and I would argue that print
along with Google Adwords is how I built
my dad's wine retail business but when I
look at what print is asking for full
page ads and top Publications today
versus its current circulation versus
the common sense of are people actually
consuming that ad in the print format or
are they consuming the information
I think it's a real challenge to justify
the rates when you can be doing I mean I
would argue outdoor is a stronger Roi
even though a lot of people are looking
at their phone in the car now and that's
got its own challenges look I'm not just
blindly digital I think a lot of digital
advertising is really bad and overpriced
I think a lot of pre-roll I think a lot
of banner ads I think a lot of the
programmatic digital ads are just there
to spray pray and disrupt and I don't
believe they're being consumed but I
just yeah I'm not super fond of the
costs associated with print ads as a
whole there's always places where you
can find pockets of value I think if
you're really thinking about traditional
means I think Drive Time radio com is is
a more interesting dollar spent and so
yeah that's that that was the point I
was making and it was also contextual I
was talking to an industry that spends
quite a bit of money a lot of money
there and I think underspend in some of
the Contemporary social aspects where I
think they would get more relevance and
actual consumption I look at web3 a lot
I've done a lot of work in it but I I
don't believe that humans are in VR
devices yet at any kind of scale that
anybody in the ad age audience would be
interested in I think the adage audience
is a little over romantic about the past
and values the past a little too much
some group of us in Fortune 5000
marketing Fortune 500 marketing we get
overzealous of the future and we do
things in VR and things as such and you
know our hypothesis is that there's an
underestimation and an undervaluing of
today
and I think today you know it's funny
sometimes I always you know I have a
funny thing that I like dream up what
would I call the company
if if I knew it better when I called it
vaynermedia and one of the things I
think about I would call my agency is
today because I think I realize a lot of
our growth over the last 13 years and
what I think is making us sustainable
and keeping our clients and what's
working is we do have a deep Obsession
about today uh I'll give you a good one
that's probably on a lot of our minds
you can't imagine how many times Garrett
a day I get text emailed or dm'd about
what happens if Tick Tock gets banned my
answer is nothing and everything what I
mean by that
we follow attention if Tick Tock is
banned that's above my pay grade that's
you know a US Government decision we
then realize the next day you're talking
about hundreds of millions of people's
attention is going to be reallocated so
what happens the next day we triple down
on shorts we triple down on Spotlight on
snap we triple down on Instagram reels
we quadruple down on Facebook reels
which we're finding a lot of winning
with right now so you know to me we
focus on today we keep an eye on
tomorrow because we want to be ready for
AI at scale we want to be ready for VR
at scale we want to be ready for AR at
scale and then we challenge
for a common sense consumer debate
around yesterday is the production cost
to this commercial that's going to run
on television is that really Roi
positive against the attention and
consideration that it would create and
so I'm not social media doubt I'm not
digital doubt I mentioned my Affinity
for Drive Time radio earlier in this
interview I'm off the charts on Super
Bowl I think influencer marketing is
incredibly underpriced and or overpriced
if you don't know how to do it we try to
stay unemotional but we try to focus on
today and we try to focus on brand
building and driving sales or results
today I for a living pay attention where
consumer attention is
and I try to figure out where that is
and I figure out how to bring value to
that attention through written form
audio video and pictures
if tick tocks off the board that
attention goes like we said earlier to a
lot of new places and it will be mine
and my agency's job to understand CTV
fast TV social traditional you know
digital 1.0 linear like where is that
got where is that attention gone and how
do we fill that with compelling
messaging to create relevance and
consideration for the outcomes that we
want right now I'm very focused on this
thing we call pack
platforms and culture we believe the way
to win in Social is to be great at
understanding the platforms the
algorithms the features what filters
work what are you able to do on them is
it a carousel this is it a reel over an
infeed and then the culture what's
happening in pop culture who are the
most interesting musicians uh what meals
are emerging what restaurants what
regions in America is fishing culture
doing this you know what's the summer
Anthem going to be what's like culture
if you do those two things extremely
well the output of the creative you do
in Social can be affected by that if you
do that well the consumer insights both
Quantum qual that you can get out of
that kind of work really can feed your
above the line and brand building you
know I think Brands need to make the
decisions for themselves you know we're
you know as an agency we're always in
support of what brands make decisions
and we follow that lead look I don't
think we can avoid angst or negativity
period there's angst and negativity in
traditional media there's angst and
negativity on websites there's anxiety
negativity on literally every platform
from Tick Tock to Facebook to Instagram
to Snapchat I you know these platforms
are empty and humans
are filling them and I think that
there's just a lot of angst in general
in society and that's showing up uh on
these platforms just like when there was
optimism and Euphoria when these
platforms showed up 15 20 years ago I
think that's just the bell curve I think
humans are being exposed I think that a
lot of people have to work on gratitude
and accountability and and putting
things into perspective but I'm very
empathetic to why there is so much angst
you know I think as far as brands
if brands are being honest and not
Hypocrites they will see angst and
negativity on every single platform
that they do marketing on and you know
that's up to Brands to make decisions on
where they want to be and where they
don't want to be
in Vayner right now we're being cautious
I think one of the things that we
recognize is we don't know the source of
the information so as you can imagine
Garrett we're trying to be very
thoughtful of like copyright and
trademark those are things we need to be
very careful of so we're kind of quote
unquote staying away from it right now
other than using it internally and
trying to get a sense of it make sure
we're not behind the bell curve you know
I think it's going to make the world
more interesting I think it's going to
commoditize some things that is going to
change the landscape no different than
the tractor did for farming so but I
also think it's going to help the
critical thinkers and the most creative
in our industry I think once you grasp
how to be good at AI it's the critical
thinking and the creative thinking input
that people are going to put into these
Algos into these platforms into these
search bars and I think it's going to
create really Dynamic work and so I
think at first people are going to meet
it with fear they did that with the
internet they did that with social media
they did that with the iPhone but I
think over the next three to five years
we'll have a more healthy view on it
that I find will be balanced meaning
there'll be some pros and there'll be
some cons like everything but I think
for our industry I believe the most
creative people in our industry are
going to flourish in an AI world because
she or he is going to be able to input
so many different creative takes into
these Ai infrastructures and they're
going to get output that's going to be
meaningful and they're going to be able
to build on that and I I'm actually
pretty excited what it's going to be for
the creative class
[Music]
foreign